what this tells me
is again even when you feel like
something saturated or there's massive
competition 80
000 channels have a minimum of 100 000
subscribers this is why signal filer
told us that being a content creator in
general is the fastest growing small
business type I think around a thousand
subscribers you essentially are probably
able to have your own sustainable
full-time online business
so you've decided to go all in on
YouTube and maybe you even know what
Niche you're in and what topic you're
talking about but you haven't nailed the
exact videos that you want to do next or
maybe you're still confused and still in
the experiment phase trying to figure
out what type of content to talk about
well in today's video we're going to be
talking all about Trends and the next
videos that you should make that will
help you get views where you're sharing
some of our best video content and some
of the strategies behind how to make
great videos that get views because
that's what you need on YouTube my name
is Heather Torres and you're listening
to the think media podcast the number
one podcast where we help you grow your
influence with YouTube and then use that
influence to grow a high impact and a
high profit YouTube channel and we
release a brand new episode every single
Tuesday so if you're new here consider
subscribing wherever you're consuming
this content from well today we are
going deeper into the types of videos
you should be creating there's real
strategy when it comes to what works on
YouTube what videos people want to watch
and why people are clicking those videos
Sean's going to break that down in
today's episode so lean in for the
featured content
[Music]
the next level of growth on your YouTube
channel is on the other side of you
posting your next best video and in this
episode of the think media podcast I
want to talk about some very specific
video ideas that are around some data
and some trends that were reviewed
really in 2020 but are still super
prevalent today so let's get straight
into them and then at the end I'll do a
recap and break down some very practical
video ideas that you can use to get more
views get more subscribers and grow your
channel faster so number one is this
videos with variations of the word
beginner in the title increased more
than 50 percent between between March
and July of 2020 so as we are even in
2021 now nevertheless the world has
changed forever I think because of the
pandemic it caused people to reevaluate
their life their job their priorities
maybe they lost a job so they had to
reinvent themselves and so a lot of
people had extra time on their hands and
therefore they even discovered the
ability to learn new skills to start a
new hobby to start a YouTube channel to
start social media marketing to to start
trying to figure out how to make money
online
and so specifically the word beginner in
the title exploded during that time but
I would encourage you it's still one of
the best possible video ideas you could
create have you made a video yet focused
on beginners globally these videos get
more than 9 billion views in 2020 words
with variations of beginner 66 of people
in Germany use YouTube to develop a new
hobby in 2020 and a whopping 94 in India
uh used YouTube to learn to do things
themselves and so here's a couple stats
and this is again from data last year
that's relevant for this year but views
of beauty tutorials increased by nearly
50 percent in 2020. there was a 90
percent increase in bike maintenance and
repair videos as an aside uh it was
interesting my friend chalene Johnson
talks about flipping a lot of stuff and
selling stuff on Poshmark and on
Facebook Marketplace things like roller
skates bikes went through the roof
because of of course people were looking
for Alternative forms of transportation
but also just alternative things to do
so anything that people started doing
more of they are learning about and
researching on YouTube daily views for
raising chickens in the title increased
by 160 percent videos related to
learning guitars saw 160 million views
from mid-march to mid-april videos
containing gardening saw six million
views in the same period and of course
chickens gardening even speaks to the
mentality of people thinking about wow
what if we're on lockdown and we can't
get food what if there's some sort of
disruption to the food chain how
sustainable is my business and my life
or is my family in our food supply so I
want to share this data with you to be
thinking about not only video ideas you
can create but how are you paying
attention and preparing for just shifts
in human psychology and behavior
Behavior based on what's happening in
the world sure lockdowns are softening
vaccines are rolling out but
nevertheless these Trends have shaped
the world forever so what kind of videos
can you re create in response there was
a 215 increase in Daily uploads of
videos related to self-care I think
mental health self-care I'm trying
that's a huge Trend right there was a
458 percent increase in Daily views and
videos about making sourdough bread it
makes me think of Mary who's one of our
video ranking Academy students she's
grown from zero
to over 300 000 subscribers she helps
people make bread helps people pickle
vegetables helps people do all kinds of
different things and as people are home
more think about this she never knew
that was going to happen she was posting
videos consistently but one of her
Channel blew up because a certain shift
in culture happened and she got to ride
that wave and there was a 200 increase
in Daily views and recipes for bubble
tea videos of how to for home haircuts
also spiked in April and so yes we're
not as locked down as we once were but
people their entire behaviors have
shifted some people shopped online for
the first time in 2020 and now they're
doing all their shopping online some
people realize they could learn a new
skill in 2020 for the first time but now
in 2021 in this whole decade they're
like man my whole life can change I
don't have to travel as much as I once
did or I could be more sustainable from
home or you know they establish new
habits and behaviors so the big question
of today's episode is what videos can
you make in response to these Trends the
second big one is people watched a
hundred billion hours of gaming on
YouTube in 2020. that is crazy I mean
this doesn't mean that I'm asking you to
change your Niche or even to potentially
pay attention to gaming but it's knowing
that gaming is massive did you know that
Esports is going to be bigger than
Sports it might already be that right
now whether it's the NBA in the NHL and
base and in fact all sports combined
will not even compare to Esports maybe
you didn't know that people Gather in
stadiums to watch people play video
games that people watch from around the
world you can watch Netflix specials on
things like League of Legends that can
attract I think like 12 million viewers
to watch Championship matches of those
types of things Starcraft 2. gaming is
massive and right now there's more than
40 million active gaming channels on
YouTube and more than 80 000 of those
channels have a minimum of 100 000
subscribers what this tells me
is again even when you feel like
something saturated or there's massive
competition 80
000 channels have a minimum of 100 000
subscribers this is why signal filer
told us that being a content creator in
general is the fastest growing small
business type I think around a thousand
subscribers you essentially are probably
able to have your own sustainable
full-time online business that's 80 000
small businesses and as those channels
grow sometimes they're employing others
employing editors and scaling and
becoming media companies Minecraft was
the most watched game with 201 billion
views and Roblox was at 75 billion views
uh as well and there's other uh games
that are of course popping as well and
one thing you may not know is that think
media has a channel that we don't tell
anybody about that is actually based on
a popular game and it's actually
compilations and footage that other
people it's not even a game I play it's
an editor edits the videos for it a
scriptwriter reads a voiceover for it
the topic it's called a faceless Channel
and this just kind of illustrates that
you can potentially pay attention to
where Trends are and create content in
those Trends because if there's massive
viewership then there's massive
opportunity number three 72 percent of
people use YouTube to exercise or keep
fit in 2020. this shouldn't surprise us
right we already knew we could turn on a
workout video or a yoga video
on YouTube but that massively exploded
so if you're in the fitness Niche if
you're moving into fitness if you want
to get fit then you can know that
there's lots of good Fitness content on
YouTube there was a 515 percent increase
in videos with home workout in the title
in March alone and some people look to
develop very specific Fitness skills
listen to this there was a 195 increase
in daily video on how to do a handstand
and people are sitting around they want
to learn new things dance workout videos
saw 180 million views from mid-march to
mid-may why not only Dance Workout but
people want to learn dances they want
dance tutorials people want to grow
their Tick Tock following by learning
dances from tutorials on YouTube that
can help them Master those moves number
four daily videos with home office in
the title increase increased 210 percent
in March 2020. so as I share some of
these you might say Sean you know I
don't do Fitness I don't do gaming but I
want you to hear all of these because
now we're on one that actually really
impacted think media
not only were we uh already working from
home and we had already covered in the
past things like standing desks and I'm
a huge proponent of productivity from
home and thinking about optimizing your
battle station in your home office but
that was one of the things we doubled
down on in response to that Trend and
we've had some videos breaking out about
our home office setups so if we teach
Tech so things like desks and webcams
and lighting all that stuff just
continued to explode but here's the
thing it's not going back we've learned
that in real estate that people are now
realizing that you there's no need to go
back to a lot of in-person work we can
do a lot of remote work and in real
estate people are looking for homes that
have a home office and some way to work
from home so daily uploads with the
videos daily uploads of videos with at
home in the title increased 700 percent
how to do your Niche at home how to you
know build in an office at home how to
just people are at home more what video
ideas could you create that have to do
with people working from home being at
home and then videos with a combination
of quarantine and routine in the title
saw 10.5 million views in just March
alone last year so people want the new
morning routine homeschool morning
routine how to
stay married during quarantine words
like these are key words doing during
trending times I want to ask you to also
think about what are the key words of
the now trending times what are the
current trends because your next
breakthrough on YouTube or your first
breakthrough on YouTube is on the other
side of talking about the right Topic at
the right time with the right title and
the right thumbnail when you talk about
the Right video that comes at the right
time when that's what people are
thinking about it can change everything
for your YouTube channel and your growth
number five daily YouTube live streams
increased 45 percent in the first six
months of 2020. this is not surprising
in a year when Live Events were for the
most most part canceled now even in 2021
it's still kind of a weird time are we
really going back to Live Events some
people are doing them we know we're
going all in with our event grow
withvideolive.com it's a virtual event
because for this year we still want to
play it safe and still respect the the
general atmosphere of if people feel
comfortable traveling some people are
like yeah it's no big deal like I'm
there I want to come do it in person
we're like we get that but a large
percentage of people still don't want to
what does that mean it means that right
now you got to be leaning into live
streaming this is something that no
matter who you are listening to this I
hope you're live streaming 53 of live
stream viewers say that watching live
streams helps them feel more connected
to something larger than themselves and
56 percent of people say that watching
live streams can be as good as being at
an event in person and this is one
reason why I think you should go live to
keep that connection going with your
community and another thing that this
looks like is not just YouTube live you
know here at think media we have what is
called our YT impact challenge it's our
YouTube impact Challenge and if you
haven't signed up for it yet go to
ytimpact.com and we are there live and
you get uh Tony's tip of the day and
Heather Taurus's sessions and giveaways
from Melissa Caputo and we do this event
and especially whether a there's
lockdowns or people aren't comfortable
traveling or just B it helps us connect
globally for some people maybe Jumping
On a Plane you've got kids but you want
to be a part of something bigger two
things make sure to be a part of our
Challenge and secondly how can you
incorporate live streaming specifically
YouTube live streaming and we'll also
drop some show notes uh resources in the
show notes because we have done
definitely some training to help you get
started with live streaming if you
haven't done it yet number six
50.9 percent of B2B decision makers use
YouTube to research purchases
so this is B2B one out of two B to B
decision makers are using YouTube to
make purchases think about it in this
case I could think of especially for a
lot of businesses they're maybe thinking
about software how are they doing their
like slack or Basecamp or monday.com how
are they doing Team Management
QuickBooks how are they doing accounting
how are they maybe researching different
companies that are going to handle
different aspects of their business or
it could be anything it could be B2B it
could be buying your next Fleet of
vehicles you know uh what which model of
vehicle do we want we need a fleet of
Chevy trucks like whatever it is so this
applies I think to product reviews
product tutorials and videos like that
that you could create that if you serve
B2B but even B to C have you what
product reviews could you do what
product tutorials could you do
that makes it the most used social
platform for this purpose did you know
that even outranking Facebook and
Linkedin people go to YouTube B2B to
make buying decisions crazy showing the
influence and the authority of YouTube
number seven seventy percent of viewers
bought from a brand after seeing it on
YouTube
so they might have seen it on YouTube in
an influencer marketing integration they
might have seen it on YouTube as a
YouTube ad they might have seen it as a
product review on YouTube the point
punchline being
that when I want information
about making a buying decision that
YouTube is going to be a major influence
70 of people viewing purchase from that
brand after so what does that mean for
you well uh I know most of people in our
community you are the Creator you're the
one that's in the content you're making
the YouTube channel or you're going to
start your YouTube channel but for a lot
of business owners have you considered
working with other influencers because
that's influencer marketing on YouTube
could be a powerful way to get the word
out about your content and it doesn't
have to be a million subscriber channels
it could be what's called micro and Nano
influencers people with five thousand
thirty thousand subscribers and you
actually collaborate with them reach out
with them and get your product
integrated into their videos but the
other thing is making a YouTube ad like
YouTube advertising is very powerful and
the influence it has is that after
people are exposed to a brand they make
a decision and then number eight YouTube
ads targeted by intent have 100 higher
lift purchase intent than those targeted
by demographics which simply means that
YouTube is unique compared to even
advertising on platforms like Facebook
on Facebook you target people by
interest oh I want to Target people who
like the UFC that are men that are 35 to
45 because your beard oil will probably
be something that those men will love
great well on YouTube uh you can Target
by intent you just doesn't matter if
they're what age they are if they like
UFC or not if they Googled how to grow
my beard Fuller then Google pays
attention to that and you can Target ads
based on intent what people are watching
what people are searching is what is who
Those ads will be shown to and this has
a 30 per two percent higher lift and AD
recall which means that it just they're
outperforming add format and so I know
that for you might be like listen I'm
not to ads yet I'm not doing digital ads
yet but some of you are and some of you
want to reach more customers grow your
business faster and leverage digital
advertising to grow your business
YouTube is a major platform where you
could create a video ad there's other AD
formats but one of those ads where
you're normally clipping click and Skip
on the ad I'm talking about you being in
that's your video and you're getting in
front of people that have the intent
they've already raised their hand to say
that they would probably be interested
in your product your service or business
so the bottom line let's recap it I know
this has been super heady but I want to
kind of give you some handles around
this around the question of what video
are you going to make next
what video are you going to make next
based on Trends based on what's
Happening Now a lot of this was what
started by the pandemic started in 2020
and much of it still happening but
what's happening now in your world and
what video should you make next to
trigger more growth than ever before
I'll hit you with a Rapid Fire recap
number one is there any beginner videos
you can make maybe you're talking too
fancy go back and make a beginner video
like your Niche for beginners three tips
for beginners this thing for beginners
in your Niche number two what tutorials
could you make any tutorials about a
product related to your Niche things
that your people would be interested in
your viewer would be in number three
what how-to videos could you make people
wanted to learn stuff and guess what
they still want to learn stuff and
they're learning whoa you can learn
anything on YouTube people are going to
YouTube to solve problems have you made
a how-to video even if this is maybe
outside of the content you normally make
I challenge you to experiment with some
of these video ideas because if you make
a tutorial or a how-to video you might
be surprised how much your current
subscribers love it and how much growth
it actually triggers gaming is big and
getting bigger is there anything related
to gaming or even referencing gaming
that you could talk about I think about
Eric Sue who we had on the think
marketing podcast he's an entrepreneur
marketer business coach his book is
called leveling up and it's actually
about gaming because guess what people
who follow you and like what you do also
have other Hobbies so sometimes it
doesn't mean you start a gaming channel
it means you can potentially just
connect with people who understand and
think a certain way number five
from home is a massive trend
work out an exercise from home home
office you know home office spaces what
can what's related to your Niche that
could help people at home what are some
of the trends that you could continue to
go deeper on for people that are trying
to make food at home work from home
survive at home self-care at home home
school at home or whatever else number
six have you tried live streaming on
YouTube yet and when could can you
schedule a live stream plan out a live
stream check out show notes and
resources for tools to help you live
stream we love stream yard and we have a
whole Suite of tools at
thinkmediatools.com that can serve you
what's a live show you could start
you know we started our show coffee with
candle we started the think media
podcast live show with Heather Taurus
and we started these new shows simple
shows no fancy music no fancy graphics
just going live consistently done is
better than perfect and they built a lot
of momentum for us here at think media
because we were connecting with people
going deeper getting more content out
there sharpening our own Saw Sharpening
our own acts like having being forced to
communicate being forced to show up and
come up with the title it's time to do
the show what are we talking about this
week like challenge yourself to start a
show every other week or once a week
just a live show that's really simple
something you could consider what's a
product you could review in your Niche
you don't have to be a product review
Channel
you could just review a product in your
Niche what products could you do a
tutorial on if you normally give advice
on how to Market and reach customers
could you do a product tutorial on click
funnels or on an email CRM because the
same people you're trying to help also
would want to watch that if you normally
help people with design advice and ideas
and it's not just general design tips
maybe there's a particular tool or a pad
with a pen for drawing and doing design
that you could review or software that
you could review so many different
products and product tutorials and
product reviews can really help you grow
and then finally do you have something
for sale online if so start using
YouTube ads and that could be a major
way for you to grow this year man I know
your brain probably hurts and Heather's
going has got some really important
information for us to uh go for next
steps on how to grow this year but I
want you to put at least one of these
video ideas I know I gave you like 10
summary things what's your next video
just what is your next video that could
very much be your best video that could
trigger massive growth in your channel
because listen YouTube's blowing up
YouTube is amazing and there's never
been a better time to go all in with
YouTube and it's gonna be on the other
side of your next best video
so that was a great summary of the types
of videos you should be creating and it
makes me think about during lockdown
there were two things that I really got
involved in and I'm so grateful that
people made content for beginners that
was John's number one tip do for
beginner content I bought a brand new RV
well it wasn't brand new it was a 1998
but it was brand new to me I never owned
a tool before and I decided to renovate
an entire 29-foot RV but because of the
power of YouTube and because creators
just like you were creating specific
content for a trend like renovation I
was able to not only learn how to use
the tools but create a beautiful project
the next thing was my family and I
decided to adopt a puppy now if you've
never had a puppy before it is
intimidating and there was so much to
learn I binge watched so much YouTube
trying to figure out all the things that
I needed to know because people were
creating content for beginners all the
way back to the puppy stage I was able
to not only have a dog that I love but
have a well-mannered and well-behaved
dog so my advice to you start with
creating that beginner content it may
feel like it's too beginner but I can
guarantee you from being someone on the
other side looking up information I want
the newbie newbie newbie stuff that I
need to know so that's my advice to you
and your next step with us here on the
podcast may be to join our free five-day
YouTube impact challenge this is another
challenge that we're doing here at think
we do them several times per year and if
you've done a challenge with us before
then you'll definitely want to make sure
that you sign up for this one as well if
you've not experienced a think challenge
then you are in for a ride we're going
to be covering things like what types of
videos you should be creating how to get
over the fear of being on camera and how
you can go deeper with helping the
community that you love so make sure you
sign up for this free free five-day
challenge at ytimpact.com and if you're
getting value out of this podcast today
I want to encourage you to press
subscribe wherever you're listening but
also if you are on iTunes rate and
review this podcast that helps us get
this podcast in front of other
entrepreneurs and purpose-driven people
just like you so all you need to do is
rate and leave a review and you might be
featured on the podcast today we have
hcd on the podcast review of saying
think media rocks this team of YouTube
marketers makes all the difference in
all caps in teaching and motivating me
to build my channel for success that's
exactly what we're doing we're here for
you to help you build a successful and
sustainable YouTube channel we know that
this is hard work and we want to help
you learn from the mistakes that we've
made so you don't have to make them and
you can start to make a high impact and
in high profit online business well
thank you so much for listening to
today's podcast I want to encourage you
to share this podcast with a friend I'm
sure you know a purpose-driven
entrepreneur in your life someone who's
creative and needs to be on YouTube or
maybe you need to go back and listen to
this podcast again so you can just share
it with your friends as you're in your
normal day-to-day conversations with
them thank you so much for being here
and we'll see you in the next episode
[Music]
foreign